- Welcome back, everyone.
My name is Heinrich.
This is my channel, Firm Learning,
when I talk about what
it takes to be successful
in the first years of your career.
And today, you'll find me at
a bit of an unusual place.
I'm currently in our
flat in Italy, in Milan.
For those of you who don't
know, I'm half Italian.
So parts of my family
still lives in Italy,
here in Milan, to be precise,
which is why here I'm enjoying the weekend
with members of the
family, visiting the city,
visiting the university, where
I spent a semester abroad
during my undergraduate years here,
the Bocconi Business School in Milan.
Great memories, for sure.
A great experience.
But today, what this video
is going to be all about
is talking about the challenges,
the questions that you might
have as a young professional.
So as someone who is in the first years
of his or her career, I know
that this can be difficult.
I experienced this myself
when I was in my first years
as a fellow business analyst
and associate working for the
consulting firm, McKinsey.
Surely this is not always easy.
So I asked you on Instagram
what the biggest challenges
and questions are
that you face during the
time, so let's get into that.
I will do my best to give you
some perspectives on these.
Now, based on the survey
I did on Instagram,
I've got several questions and challenges
from people like you saying
that their colleagues or clients
telling that you are too young.
So how to get over that?
What is my experience?
And yes, I can relate to that
because I did have several instances
while working in consulting
and also later in the job
where there were people on the team
that were not really that
well-accepted by clients,
that got comments,
especially in the beginning,
especially due to their age.
And often, it's not even
due to their actual age,
but often just also to the perceived age.
Of course, it doesn't
help to look very young.
Hear my experiences, though,
that over the course of working together
over the course of such a relationship,
you can overcome this
just by being helpful
and really adding value to the client.
And indeed, what you can
do as a junior person
is often not so much winning
with industry domain expertise.
Of course, you will often
not be the biggest expert
of what is going in an industry.
You will not have already seen it all,
but what often the skill is
that you can bring to the table,
especially in the consulting context,
especially if you're
already analytically minded
is really the power of data.
So it's really difficult
to argue with you,
even if you're very young and
you look very inexperienced,
if you're sitting in a
meeting and you conducted
a well-researched,
well-carried out analysis,
and now you're confronting
people with facts,
with numbers, with data.
If you do this well, if
you present this well,
I mean, it's very difficult
to try argue with you.
And if you show that you can do that,
if you show that you
really have some insights,
that you can contribute, by doing this,
you will get taken seriously.
The next one is to ask
the right questions.
So maybe exactly because you're
not that experienced yet,
sometimes you may struggle
to really come up with
good and helpful questions.
You wonder, maybe, how can
you contribute in meetings?
And you want sneaky little
tip that I picked up over time
is that especially if you
have an important meeting,
you are maybe a junior,
having a document that is being presented,
think about this in advance.
Go over the document and
look at some good pages
and think about what things would be
that you would be able to ask in a meeting
that would be really insightful,
that really maybe also
would make you look good,
make you look smart.
And then at the right times,
if the situation allows it,
ask for these things.
And independent of how you see it,
certainly if you prepare a bit,
have a bit more time in advance,
it will be much easier for
you really to add value,
ask the right things,
ask meaningful questions
than if you just sit in the
meeting not really prepared
and you come up with things
like that on the spot.
The next one is to how to
interact with managers,
colleagues, and clients at
the beginning of a new job
because they don't know
you don't know them,
so how you interact with them.
Surely here's now lots of
things that can be said
on all different types of nuances to that.
One tip that I want to share
that I think makes a lot of sense
and really can make a difference
is that especially in the first weeks
on a new product in consulting
or in the first months
if you work in industry,
really try to give 200%, give 300%.
Go above and beyond
because my experience
is if you've established
this reputation in the beginning,
that you are really this superstar,
that you are this rockstar consultant,
that you are this like top
one-percenter per year,
if this is the reputation
that you established in the beginning,
this will go a very long way.
Maybe unable to continue
like this forever,
and of course, that's okay,
but I would absolutely be
cautious of is where to start
rather than the opposite,
to start a bit slower,
maybe a bit insecure, not doing that much.
This often is difficult
because then you have the opposite effect,
then to recover from that and
turn this reputation around
is really then a long
way that you need to go.
Next thing is about dealing
with imposter syndrome.
So what do you do if you feel like
you really have imposter syndrome,
that you don't really deserve to be here,
that it feels like all these other people
are so much smarter than you are?
And I for sure remember this.
I very, very remember the first weeks
on my very first project in consulting.
I felt like I should not be here.
I felt like I was working
together on a team
with other associates, other consultants,
and these people seemed
so above and beyond,
so much smarter, so
much more capable of me.
I really remember after
the first weeks, wondering,
asking myself whether I am the
right person to do this job,
whether I would, at any point,
be able to be only half
as good as these people.
But the truth is the
learning curve is quite steep
and what you will only see
is that where these are,
maybe one year tenure, two years tenure,
this is such a development
step from where you are
or someone who just started out
compared to someone who's
already doing all of this
after one or two years,
because what you don't
realize in the beginning
is that there are lots
of little tips and tricks
that might make you to be
perceived as very confident,
very knowledgeable, even if
maybe in this specific moment,
you are not necessarily that confident
and that well knowledgeable, right?
And actually, I even did
a video about this topic
a couple of weeks or months ago.
I will link at somewhere above here,
where I share some of these
sneaky little tips and tricks,
what consultants, and of
course, also many other people
that are outside of consulting
sometimes do to really create
this very positive
perception about themselves,
which maybe is not really always backed up
with hard knowledge, right?
And of course, that's just
part of the game as well.
You will see this in all different types
of professional services context,
and for sure also in industry,
but learning these little things
and then of course over time,
also getting the actual
hard industry knowledge,
by all of this, it's very
likely that in one or two years,
you will suddenly be this
quite experienced consultant,
associate who works
together with a new joiner,
and trust me,
this new joiner very
likely will look up to you
and think the very same things
that you thought in the beginning.
So I guess just trust the process.
Of course, learn, be
open-minded, learn the game,
learn the skills, and you will be fine.
The next one is about setting boundaries.
How can you, even if you work
in a high-paced environment
with of course, long
hours, lots of pressure,
how do you succeed to set boundaries
to also still carve out
some time for yourself?
And of course, this is
often especially challenging
in professional services like consulting,
probably even more in banking,
where just so much is expected from you.
But hear also my experiences.
The people often that struggled most
were really the new
joiners, the junior people
who are only in the firm
for a couple of months,
and then often, these people feel like
they need to do everything
they're asked to do.
They always need to say
yes, whatever it takes,
but then it was often the bit
more experienced associates,
one year, second year,
third year associate
who knew the game a little bit better
and that did manage quite well
also to fence off some time,
set these boundaries,
and thereby also manage
their work-life balance.
And it did how to
achieve this, my tidbits,
that it's very fair to, for
instance, in the beginning,
have a conversation with
your project leader,
with your team to
industry, wherever you work
that you very clearly state
what is important to you
also regarding lifestyle.
And of course, it's
important to be realistic.
So like if you work for
an NBB consulting firm
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain,
if you tell this project lead
that you just expect that every evening,
you are done with work at 8:00 PM,
I mean, this is just completely
not realistic, right?
So this will not work.
But what will work is that
maybe you tell this project lead
that it's important to you
that at least one evening during the week,
then at least a bit earlier
at 8:00 or 9:00 PM or so,
you have this evening to
yourself, having flexibility,
for instance, to go to the
hotel, hit the hotel gym,
and then if there's more work to do,
then maybe afterwards
you can do that, right?
Just as an example.
Or maybe you state that
it's very important to you
that every lunchtime, you get a warm meal,
because maybe this is
really what matters to you.
You feel like if you don't
have proper lunch every day,
then you struggle to
really do your job well.
I mean, clearly state
expectations like this
and if you clearly communicate this
and then also act on that,
then my experience is
everyone will understand,
everyone will be okay
if they're maybe even a
bit earlier than the rest.
Maybe the rest of the team
is then still working from the team room,
but then you leave a bit
earlier on that specific day
to hit the gym
because you clearly said that
this is important to you.
Another thing that several
of you asked is my opinion
on the point of specialization
versus generalization.
So at the beginning of your career,
should you rather choose a
path that leads you towards
a general experiencing
lots of different things,
a more specialized one where
you build deep domain knowledge
in a specific area?
And here, certainly both paths
can lead to great success
and I trust you can build a great career
based on both of the types of things.
In my humble opinion, I do think
that there's a lot of value
in that in the beginning of your career,
really follow the generalist approach.
See lots of different things.
This is, of course,
what you will be able to do
in many consulting roles,
so you'll start in a generalist track
and then in the first
one, two, or three years,
have the opportunity to see
lots of different industries,
lots of different functions.
I think this has two main benefits.
First, of course,
by exposing yourself to many
of these different areas,
probably this will help you
to make a more informed decision
which area maybe at a
later stage in your career,
you already want to focus
on, but then second,
and this is really where I'm
also drawing from right now
and having worked after
consulting in a retail role,
right now in a startup
role in prop tech company,
after working in all
these different functions
and industries, getting
this broad experience,
what this helps a bit is confidence,
confidence that you are able to navigate
lots of different environments,
that you are able to add value
in many, many different areas
and instances of work.
And this confidence, I think,
is very easy to undervalue,
to underestimate.
I think it's quite an asset
that you have the mindset,
that yes, more or less
independent of what the setting is
that you will enter in
your professional life,
also after professional services
if you're anti-industry at some point,
doesn't matter what area exactly you work,
and you learn some tools
to make you successful in this area,
you have the confidence
that, yes, you can add value.
I would not underestimate then
what the value of this is.
I do think, at least for me personally,
it made quite a difference.
And if you have the opportunity
to collect this more
generalist experience,
I do think that it's
worthwhile to follow that
because then always after some time,
there's still lots of
opportunities to specialize.
But to the contrary,
if you're already specialized
in a quite significant way
in the first years of your career,
I would argue it's then quite difficult
to then move towards a more
general manager type of path,
to move towards a path
where then you do see different things.
So do this in the beginning.
I think this is, in my humble
opinion, the sweet spot.
I also got several
questions on communication,
so how to communicate effectively,
how to structure your
messages the right way
and so on and so forth.
Of course, here, also
many things to be said.
I created several videos
on communication-related
topics in the past.
I will link above here a
playlist where you find them
and now a shameless plug,
it's also no secret
that I have this course,
so Professional Communications
in Slide Writing.
So if you're really serious
to improve your communications game,
I will leave a link to this course
below in the video description
where I talk a lot about
professional slide writing
communication skills.
So check this out if this
is of interest to you.
So hope this was helpful.
Of course, let me also
know in the comments
whether you enjoyed this format,
whether you'd like to see
more videos like that.
If you liked it,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
Subscribe to this channel to
see more content like this.
And of course, as always,
a big thanks to all the
members of Firm Learning.
Thanks for your support.
If you want to continue
your learning journey,
I will link additional videos here
that I believe will be valuable to you.
So until then, see you next week.
This is Heinrich from
Firm Learning and bye-bye.